on Thursday Politico announced that
Huffington Post would be taking its
readers on a voyage of discovery to
strange Uncharted lands like Vasco de
Gama venturing out into New Territories
Huffington Post will be packing a few of
its staffers onto a leaky bus and taking
them on a cross-country seven week tour
through the dark mysterious Middle
America the cost 1 million dollars yes I
am not joking
this is the story quotes starting in
September a traveling party rotating
HuffPost staff members led by
editor-in-chief
Lydia full-grain will visit more than 20
cities issuing the coasts for the likes
of Fort Worth Indiana Oxford Mississippi
and Odessa Texas at each city the site
will host events roll out plans stories
of local media outlets send out
reporters to write about the communities
and collect stories from residents in
their own words this would be identity
defining for HuffPost said Poole green
in an interview we are in a moment for
determining our own identity and the
role we play in the overall news
ecosystem and what the next iteration of
that looks like and this felt like a
great way to go out and report out the
story of who we should be in the world
don't worry gang the leftist media isn't
out of touch or anything this does show
that so-called flyover country is new to
the media their disconnect with people
who live in Texas and Oklahoma and
Alabama and Michigan and Wisconsin it's
quite real they don't understand their
values they don't understand their
lifestyles this is why CNN - Erin
Burnett mocks Christian pasture pastors
for laying hands on President Trump they
did the same for Obama but nobody cared
and why the entire media was shocked
that anybody would vote for Trump in the
first place but it weren't just suffice
to visit these places until the media
begins hiring in these areas they won't
have boots on the ground or perspective
into the places they seek to cover
jet-setting - Rose essa isn't exactly
going to provide sort of empathetic
analysis the less lacks about people
outside of New York in LA and so the
Huffington Post Tour is much more likely
to be a sort of Jeff Corwin experience
for city folk than a real educational
experience look bill what is that lady
doing going into that building with the
cross on top it's a Sunday doesn't she
know it's time for brunch at the local
coffee house I mean they serve avocado
toast and the avocados from Whole Foods
on Sundays good luck Huffington Post may
god whoa Planned Parenthood be with you
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show
so you'll get to all of the latest on
Trump Russia will also get to the latest
on Trump care the Senate has now
unveiled its new package the details are
just starting to come out some good
stuff some bad stuff we'll get to all of
that before we do I first want to say
thank you to our sponsors over at
ProFlowers so they saved me this week so
this week was my ninth anniversary with
my wife which is July 8th and we were
and and we were both busy so we sort of
both forgot about it which tends to
happen when you have kids and so I had
not gotten my wife flowers thank God
there was Pro flowers so it was late at
night I was going to run to the flower
store and my wife was going to go to
sleep anyway and so I got the flowers
from Pro flowers they were delivered to
the house they are beautiful they they
last for at least a week they are just
they're fantastic she loved them I
actually got her two vases of flowers to
make up for my stupidity and ProFlowers
made all of that happen right now
ProFlowers has a special offer just for
our listeners you get $10 off with your
purchase of $29 or more so pretty hefty
discounts this deal works great on best
selling gifts like the 100 blooms
bouquet a dozen red roses or even their
totally unique gift plants and one of
the things that that's awesome about pro
flowers that they don't just send you
the bouquet they actually send you the
vase along with it they're guaranteed
fresh for seven days or your money back
and they've a seven-step quality check
which means the flowers are always
awesome they come in the mail and no
that doesn't ruin the flowers the
flowers are in better quality than they
will be if you go to your local grocery
store their website is super easy to use
you can schedule your delivery ahead of
time for any date you want you can put a
card on there it is a no-brainer for an
anniversary if you forgot your
anniversary like I did Pro flowers is
just vital so right now go to
proflowers.com you can help yourself and
the show by going to proflowers.com get
$10 off your purchase of twenty nine
dollars or more at ProFlowers
proflowers.com and enter promo code
Ben's show it's Ben's show at checkout
to get the special deal again it's
proflowers.com
and enter that promo code Ben's show at
checkout and you get that very special
deal $10 off your purchase of $29 or
more they are a lifesaver okay so I do
want to jump into the latest on Trump
Russia and in the latest hubbub but
there's an article that I think it is
necessary to go through because it
really struck me this is why the Left
loses so the left thinks that if they
hit Trump enough on Russia that the
and people will just swivel around and
hate Trump it and what they fail to
acknowledge is the reason that people
like Trump is because they hate the left
the reason that Trump is almost
completely a reactionary phenomenon it
is the stupidity and the out of touch
nests of left that has led to the rise
of President Trump and these Republican
rubes that the left so despises is why
Trump was really the apex of this I mean
the fact is that Barack Obama lost a
thousand seats across the country in
state legislatures he lost twelve
governor's he lost ten senators and
Barack Obama devastated his party
because the left took off its mask in
the last eight years and when people saw
underneath was worse than Phantom of the
Opera and so you can see this day in and
day out when the left sort of reveals
itself so today's example of this it
actually comes from Monday there's a
column by woman named Colleen Krajewski
this was actually a column at The
Washington Post and the title of it was
I used to be quiet about the fact that I
perform abortions now I'm upfront okay
but the article is even crazier than
this and this is the left bragging about
what they do right like when I brag
about things that I do in daily life you
know if I'm going to brag about it I'll
tend to brag about like career
achievements or maybe I'll brag about
something nice that I did in terms of
giving charity maybe I'll brag about you
know the good things I do with my wife
and kids I don't typically associate I
killed somebody else's baby as as
something you brag about but not the
same I guess if you are elected so here
is what Colleen and krajewski right and
again in the Washington Post on Monday
with one of the nation's premier
newspapers right quote one month after
Donald Trump was elected president I
leaned back in a black leather chair as
a man hovered over me for the first time
in decades the fate of roe v-- wade
seemed to be in real doubt feeling a mix
of anxiety sadness and resolved I
thought I'm committed now what she's
getting an abortion no she was getting a
tattoo the tattoo artist slowly etched
on my right forearm a rather large coat
hanger the symbol of illegal abortions
that cost unknown numbers of women their
lives in the years before Roe overlaid
in bold lettering rewards never again
now as one of the udin let me say I do
not like the appropriation of the phrase
never again to apply to regulations
against the killing of unborn human
beings and this is sort of like the it
would be sort of like if the Nazis
posted a picture of a hook-nosed Jew and
then said never again you're sort of
missing the point of never again if
never again which is a phrase used for
the holic
is now used to refer to never again we
will be stopped from killing babies in
the seventh month really she continues
from now on unless I was in long sleeves
everyone I met would see my tattoo the
moment we shook hands at the office at
parties in the supermarket on first
dates now normally would say this person
is a crazy person like this is not a
great idea I'm a Republican I'm a
conservative but I don't actually tattoo
that on my arm like I don't have a
picture of Ronald Reagan tattooed on my
arm because that would be weird gang but
she actually went and she got a picture
of a hanger a coat hanger with the words
never again tattooed on there again it
could be slightly vague I mean maybe
maybe never again means don't kill
babies but apparently it's not it's
virtually signalling for her leftist
friends but that's not the worst part of
this that you got this stupid tattoo my
best my favorite part of this article is
that she goes on to talk about how
abortion her being an abortionist has
now enhanced her dating life seriously
it's what this article is about how her
abortion has enhanced her dating life
thanks to President Trump
she says embracing the symbol of the
coat hanger meant also accepting myself
as a symbol symbol which I had always
resisted but as I shed stigma of being
an abortion provider I felt free I was
tired of playing games and for the first
time in my life I was ready for someone
to love me because I provide abortions
not in spite of it okay with that tattoo
I made some other changes
no more padding my eyelashes on dates
feigning innocence or acting apologetic
about Who I am no more waiting the
requisite three days to call back or
count me on three dates to have sex if I
wanted to she goes on and she says an
unexpected side effect of the 2016
election is that many people have become
vocal about their support for
reproductive rights suddenly dating an
abortion provider can be cool a way to
proclaim one's liberal street cred yeah
I'm sure that's what guys were thinking
I'm sure they're dating this girl may go
you know what she's so awesome she kills
babies mmm yeah bring this one home to
mother and she's awesome
she third trimester second she didn't
care
she'll do it I mean okay let me just
make a quick point I have a feeling she
she links her own abortion tattoo to the
fact that you will have sex before three
dates I have a feeling that some of the
people she is dating might have the same
idea and these two things in fact maybe
that's what guys are thinking not oh
it's so awesome I'm dating a woman with
an abortion tattoo but I'm dating a
woman with an abortion catch
and maybe that means that she will be a
little bit easier to to get where I want
her to go I saw this by the way at the
2012 DNC I went to the Democratic
National Convention in 2012 and there
was a there were guys who are wearing
around pins that said I love pro-choice
girls and I thought to myself yeah I can
see that
yeah that is not a shock so I met
investment banker who was close to a
decade younger than I am for him my
profession seemed to add to the edginess
of dating an older woman I was insecure
this lady is and she's writing a
personal to ad in the Washington telex
remember this isn't that the salon is
not it's late it's in the Washington
Post right democracy dies in darkness
Washington Post like Woodward and
Bernstein Washington Post for him my
profession seems to seem to add to the
edginess of dating an older woman
there was the hard-partying Alaskan
fishermen on an extended shore break who
found my commitment to reproductive
justice hot I'm going to go with the
Alaskan fisherman on the extended shore
break did not find your commitment to
reproductive justice hot he wanted to
get in your pants and so he told you
that lady and she says so abortion
providers are hot now as time goes on I
sometimes forget about the tattoo
entirely once I wore long sleeves before
becoming intimate with a fascinating
biomedical engineer and when he first
saw the tattoo he burst out laughing
apparently delighted by my commitment to
the cause well maybe that was your read
obviously she's ended up in a long-term
relationship she's gotten everything
that she wants out of life I love that
this is like Carrie Bradshaw talking
about being an abortion provider it's
just amazing says neither the tattoo
know my perspective changed everything
there's the entrepreneur with political
aspirations who sent mixed signals and
ultimately drifted away you mean unlike
the Alaskan fisherman on shore leave
from the porno you watch three days ago
this was because I could be a liability
to him in some future election or was he
just not over his ex being more open
about what I do has not led to perfect
communication or the end of insecurity
how she concludes this column is the
whole thing further says recently and I
have to say I love the scallop I think
it's the greatest column that was ever
written I think this ranks up there with
like Cicero and with Plato I mean this
is just fantastic so recently an online
dating match messaged me and without
knowing my specialty began lamenting the
threat of sp3 he's an attorney
temporarily based in North Dakota where
he's defending standing rock protesters
of course he is our conversation about
social justice led to such a strong
connection that we
meeting despite the distance wow that
that Wow
what a love story he defends standing
rock protesters and you kill babies what
just a match made in heaven because
whatever happens I will no longer be
silent or beautiful when a new love
interest or anyone makes me feel exposed
and vulnerable as my tattoo says never
again okay so now she has applied never
again to killing babies and also telling
guys who she wants to have sex with that
she does that for a living again please
do not hijack Holocaust phrases to
justify your crappy dating life late but
this is what you wonder why Trump wins
this lady's just 100,000 votes for Trump
in Wisconsin I think Donald Trump should
actually have copies of this column
printed out and handed out to everyone
in the Midwest well done Washington Post
so this is why Trump isn't losing
support okay Trump can't lose support
because a lot of the people who support
Trump are not going to move over to the
side of Killeen krajewski or whatever
her name is they're nothing to move over
to that they're going to look at this
and go I don't want to be associated in
any way with these crazy people and if
Trump talks to some Russians whatever at
least he doesn't have an abortion tattoo
and then talk about his dating life like
really it is amazing stuff from the left
so well done leftist he's done a
wonderful job alienating every person of
decent mind and heart in America please
continue to do so as fast as possible
okay meanwhile there's more fallout from
the Donald Trump jr. Fredo Corleone
spilling of the emails yesterday as you
recall Donald Trump jr. a couple of days
ago he spilled emails
that showed that he was approached by
some nutty British promoter and that
nutty British promoter is is also the
agent for a guy that Trump did business
with in Russia and he said the Russian
government really wants to help out your
father he says it's Donald Trump jr. and
so what we want you to meet with the
Russian government lawyer who has some
dirt on Hillary Clinton and Trump yours
like yeah that was awesome and and so
you know first of all CNN uncovered
footage of Trump with Russians and I do
love the media bias here because it
pretty is it is pretty stunning CNN
uncovered this media I was watching CNN
because it was on at the gym and there's
nothing I could do about it and CNN was
playing this footage over and over and
over again like it was some sort of
smoking gun this is from I think 2013
2014 long before Trump was running for
president
the behind-the-scenes video obtained
exclusively by CNN shows then
businessman Donald Trump in Las Vegas in
2013 at several events during the
weekend of the Miss USA pageant hanging
out with the men now at the center of
the newest development in the Russia
controversy the men Russian pop singer
Amin Aguilera and his father Iraq the
real estate developer in Russia
we're helping Trump sold his Miss
Universe pageant in Moscow later that
year and the videos from the scene
having dinner with the aguillera along
with their publicist Rob Goldstone being
here leaning over to talk with Trump
right there's a boy Raja I known and
that's a les grossman from as I say from
Tropic Thunder and and then CNN think oh
we got him now we have tape okay first
of all we knew the trunk with all these
people why is this a shock in any way oh
he had dinner
okay well Barack Obama used to like hang
out with Bill Ayers and the in CNN spent
years pretending that didn't matter so
why in the world would it matter that
Trump knew these people of course from
knew these people how do you think they
had Trump Jr's email address it's just
silly
okay so Trump respond the Trump team
responds and as always they respond in
perhaps the dumbest possible way so
Kellyanne Conway leads the way and I
understand that everything is so
polarized right now that Kellyanne
Conway could basically go on Fox News
and do some arm parting and everybody
would just say that it was brilliant an
interim plan and she could do that and
then she could do this a couple of times
and all of CNN would claim that this was
in fact secret Morse code to the
Russians that we need more of their help
in the next election cycle they arm
farting is policy but here's Kellyanne
Conway doing what like this is not real
life
folks this cannot be real life here she
was with Sean Hannity this this actually
happened this was the thing this is how
you see it so far this is to help all
the people at home what's the conclusion
collusion
no we don't have that yet I see illusion
and delusion Brooke books are just over
clear everyone forwards conclusion
collusion no illusion delusion yes I
just thought we'd have some fun with
words so Sesame's Grover where is a day
for
Shaan SS Menzel over New York Post and I
think that the Trump administration has
had enough fun with words for one week
but this is it first of all confusion
okay how about that one
confusion how about some some decency
exclusion they this is all insane the
profusion ah it's giving me a contusion
this is the hope it's just ridiculous
first of all I do love the fact that
when she does this and she's holding it
up like she had to physically cross out
collusion didn't actually just make a
collusion with a strikethrough through
which is available on her word right
they actually had to have her physically
strike it out and then cross it out like
how dumb does she think voters are I
mean I guess pretty dumb like you
actually have to show up it's a
collusion conclusion illusion delusion
exclusion profusion contusion McPherson
nuclear fusion
okay alright okay like how about natural
defense here's the defense okay Donald
Trump jr. allegedly tried to collude
with the Russians to do bad stuff
nothing came of it
so as attempted collusion FS it shows
motive but it doesn't show means or
opportunity as I've been saying for two
straight days now and media have been
trying to say this was the beginning of
a nefarious collusion again one of the
things that I don't understand is what
exactly would that collusion constitute
okay let's actually say for a second
that Donald Trump jr. had somehow gotten
together with the Russians what would
that constitute remember the Trump
administration
the Trump campaign did not drop any new
material about her about Hillary Clinton
they drop anything right so I guess the
collusion would have been something like
WikiLeaks and the Russians go to trump
and they say in two days we're dropping
a new stash of emails but that's not how
it worked I mean if anyone actually
thinks back to the campaign this is not
how it work so unless Trump was
providing the Russians with material to
go out and spill or unless the Russians
were providing Trump with heads up
that's not how it worked because as I
recall now is there the entire election
cycle and so are you
as I recall there'd be a dump of
WikiLeaks and WikiLeaks was obviously
dumping because they didn't like Hillary
Clinton that doesn't mean that Trump was
behind it and then there'd be people
like me who would sift through the
WikiLeaks I mean thousands of pages of
WikiLeaks trying to find the most
damning portions and this is this is
exactly what happened during the
election cycle so to pretend like I'm
still confused as to what collusion
would actually look like all of these
would be good defensive points
going on TV and rhyming like Grover from
Sesame Street on Sean Hannity show is
not an actually good defense turns out
it's not a great David but none of this
matters I mean none of it matters
because people are stuck in their lanes
so Trump goes on with Pat Robertson
yesterday providing certainly a contrast
in visuals and and he says that the
weird thing about all of this is like
everybody keeps saying that Putin wanted
me but Putin would rather have had
Hillary as an example if Hillary had won
our military would be decimated our
energy would be much more expensive
that's what Putin doesn't like about me
and that's why I say why would he want
me because from day one I wanted a
strong military he doesn't want to say
that we're going to be self-supporting
we just about are now we're going to be
exporting energy he doesn't want that he
would like Hillary what she wants to
have windmills you know he would much
rather have that because energy prices
will go up and Russia as you know relies
very much on energy there are many
things that I do that are the exact
opposite of what he would want so when I
keep hearing about that he would have
rather had Trump I think probably not
because when I want a strong military
you know she wouldn't have spent the
money on the military but when I want a
strong military when I want tremendous
energy we're opening up coal we're
opening up natural gas we're opening up
fracking all the things that he would
hate but nobody ever mentioned said okay
so it what Trump is saying here is
actually right which is that Trump's
policies have not been particularly Pro
Russia I mean aside from some sanctions
talk there really is bit like Trump's
again Trump's White House is very weird
Trump says stuff and then his
administration does stuff and the stuff
that he says and the stuff that his
administration does are two separate
things so his administration is pursuing
some pretty vehement anti-russian
measures on certain things Trump himself
will say very warm things toward Russia
I don't buy his argument that Russia
wanted Hillary and not Trump in the last
election cycle because there's not a lot
of evidence to that effect and in fact
that email from Rob Goldstone
specifically said the Russian government
wants to help you and your campaign and
Russia has been very warm toward Trump
for years I mean predating this election
cycle but he is correct to say you know
when you say that I'm in collusion with
Russia so where's the pro quo if you're
saying there was some sort of quid like
they did me a favor where's the pro quo
what am i doing for them
to favor and the answer is not much
aside from some of the terms rhetoric
like this is an actual fair point
okay well with all of that said you know
I do want to get to other things that
Trump is doing and I want to get to the
Democrats of course doing what they do
best which is making everyone hate them
we'll get to all of that in just a
second but first I want to say thank you
to our sponsors over at Birch gold so
right now live uncertainty in the world
after the Trump jr. emails broke the Dow
Jones dropped like 100 points than five
minutes there's a lot of volatility
still in the stock market and I'm not
saying don't invest in the stock market
but I am saying it should have at least
part of your portfolio in precious
metals because if you do not have some
sort of protection against the
vicissitudes of the stock market or the
real estate market then you are setting
yourself up for trouble you should have
some money in precious metals they are
more safe they are more secure their
never work zero and that's what you can
learn by going to birchgold.com slash
pin you get a comprehensive 16 page kit
revealing how gold and silver can
protect your savings how you can legally
move your IRA or 401k out of stocks and
bonds and into a precious metals IRA to
get your no cost no obligation kit again
go to birchgold.com slash Bend that is
birchgold.com slash Ben
they have an A+ rating from the Better
Business Bureau tons of five-star
ratings as well there's books that I
trust for investment in precious metals
birchgold.com slash Ben check that out
okay so naturally the Democrats are
completely incapable of stopping
themselves and it's funny there's a
little bit of a battle that's breaking
out among the Democrats there are
Democrats who are positioning for a
presidential run in 2020 who are trying
to say let's not talk about Russia and
then you've got the people in Congress
who are saying let's talk about Russia
non-stop the reason is because of
immediacy that's the actual gap they
don't disagree with one another so Brad
Sherman yesterday who is my Congress
person yes really
California you suck so much you suck
Congress cut California anyway so Brad
Sherman he actually made a proposal that
sure that Trump should be impeached and
he introduced a bill on the floor of the
house a bill of impeachment against
Trump on the floor of the house yeah
good luck with that
why are you doing this he's not he's of
course he's not going to be impeached in
this congressional term knowing what we
know now so what would be the point of
doing this well it can have either of
two effects
the hope is that it triggers an
investigation an intervention in the
white house and this is a faint hope
that his staff is finally able to say
now it's real articles and for that and
for so many other reasons mr. president
you've got to stop announcing reversals
and foreign policy at 4:00 in the
morning and 140 characters you've got to
stop making foreign policy in complete
ignorance of the facts which say your
ear impeaching him so he'll stop
tweeting my hope is that we end in
competent impulsive government okay yeah
good luck with that all this is of
course is PR and the Democrats know then
you have the ones who are running for
president like Gavin Newsom he's going
to run for governor in California and
then he's going to run for president he
says that we should all stop talking
about Russia but he looks focus on the
issues you can tell the difference
between the guys running for the
presidency and the guys who are running
for Congress because Congress the
Democrats think they're going to win
Congress in 2018 on the Russia stuff
Democrats know that in order to win the
presidency they're going to have to do
more than just talk about Russia
so here's Gavin Newsom obviously the
media is obsessed for good reason during
the Russia story undoing prosecutors
thank you well that's where I'm what
originated how do you already explain to
Democrats out there and your face how
talking about Russian on the campaign
trail is not going to lose it back and I
don't know and more evidence you need I
mean the end of the day at the end of
the day even if you've gained this thing
out you get rid of Trump right you're
left with a guy who's you know who's out
there talking about conversion therapy
don't do anything right for the
Democratic Party in our agenda so unless
we deal with the issues of economic
anxiety cultural issues in a substantive
way and we get into how business and we
actually demonstrate with some acuity
and strength a clear conviction in terms
of the fate and future of this country
then we're never going to take that
makes me think okay so gavin newsom
obviously positioning himself for
president is that going to work for him
I don't think so Gavin Newsom is any
other Democrat he just likes to say I
phone a lot like really this is what
this is his shtick I live in California
lieutenant governor here he basically
goes around and he says all the
Democratic policies except on an iPhone
and then ever goes moo' he's tech savvy
and it's all stupidity okay so as we
continue here on the bench
I want to talk about what's going on
with Trump care I want to talk about the
new FBI nominee who had his hearings on
the hill yesterday plus some epic things
I like and things that I hate and the
big idea but for all of that are going
to have to go over to Daley wired.com
and subscribe for just $9.99 a month you
can get a subscription to daily wear
icon for those of you who listen you may
not know this but this is actually a
video show and you can watch it live and
you can continue to watch the rest of
the show live over its daily wire we
show the first 15 minutes on Facebook
and then we go live for the rest of the
show over at daily wire if you're a
subscriber so for $9.99 a month to get
the entire show live yet to be part of
the mailbag on Fridays same deal with
Andrew Clavin show which you by the way
sure to listen to and watch we're going
to be launching a new show god help us
with Michael Knowles so you can watch
that as well for $9.99 a month and for
annual subscribers $99 er you get this
unbelievable
magnificent incredible leftist here's
hot or cold tumblr okay you've never
seen anything like you've never
experienced anything like it the weight
of it the etching dishwasher-safe
incredible leftist tears beverages
whatever you wish to hold any human
blood we don't do that anything else you
can hold in this here left this here's
hot or cold tumblr with the daily wire
logo it's just magnificent and for $99
ear you get that as well as all the
other goodies including an ad-free
website and all the rest of it to go
over and check that out or you just want
to listen later on iTunes or SoundCloud
or YouTube go ahead and head over there
afterwards subscribe make sure you leave
us a comment we always appreciate it
whatever number of stars we're going to
rate us on iTunes please add 5 to it and
then and then make sure that you leave a
review
we always appreciate all of that we are
the largest conservative podcast in the
nation
[Music]
already to an actual substantive news
away from Trump Russia Trump care is
moving forward
sort of so today Mitch McConnell has now
revealed his bare-bones plan for the
Senate bill it's difficult in the Senate
because you've got conservatives like
Ted Cruz and Mike Lee and Rand Paul on
the one side and on the other side you
have Susan Collins who basically would
like to double down on Obamacare and so
trying to cobble together 51 votes is
sort of difficult Republicans can only
lose two they can only lose two making
moves to they can have 50 votes and
Pence's a tiebreaker but if they lose
three it's over it's not a lot of votes
that you can afford to lose if you
actually want to pass some sort of
change to Obamacare so Trump is outside
of course saying he wants Trump care
pass now one of the problems here is
that Trump has been absent from the
campaign trail for three days he's now
in France which is not going to Trump
carroty good if he actually wanted to
pass this thing it would be useful for
him to maybe go out on the campaign
trail and stump for and discuss the
details and talk about why it's good but
instead he sort of got these generic
comments about why he wants Trump care
passed but Trump doesn't know what the
hell isn't it obviously number one
repealing replace I am sitting in the
Oval Office with a pen in hand waiting
for our senators to give it to me now we
have a president that's waiting to sign
it I have pen in hand so now it means
something will happen if they don't well
I don't want to talk about it because I
think would be very bad I will be very
angry about it and a lot of people will
be very upset but I'm sitting waiting
for that bill to come to my desk I hope
that they do it they've been promising
it for years they've been promising it
ever since Obamacare which is failed
it's a failed experiment it is totally
gone it's out of business and we have to
get this done repeal and replace okay so
he's just saying weldings now this is
going to have no impact on Congress
because the problem is you know that
even if you pass something if it starts
to go bad Trump isn't going to turn on
you and blame you right he did this with
the house they passed a bill and then he
promptly turned around and crapped all
over the bill by calling it mean mean
mean so Trump doesn't have a lot of
weight here so what does this new
Obamacare replacement bill actually look
like there are two there are several
major problems with the Obamacare
replacement bill in some ways it got
better in some ways it actually got
worse so they restored a bunch of the
tat
says that they'd cut in the original
Senate bill in the bizarre hope that
somehow this will lead Democrats to now
think that they don't have to attack
them for their slogan has been that
they're cutting health care for poor
people from Medicaid in order to
subsidize tax cuts for the wealthy right
this is the way that they left puts it
so the Republicans cut a lot of the tax
cuts for the wealthy but they left a
couple they left some and that means the
Democrats are going to say the exact
same thing so you really have not won
anything have you now they also have
said Mitch McConnell is apparently
encouraging people he's telling
moderates to support the health care
bill including the Medicaid cuts because
quote they will never go into effect
anyway okay so in other words the entire
selling point the Paul Ryan selling
point we're going to restructure
Medicaid it doesn't even apply according
to Mitch McConnell so basically they're
lying to all of you and Mitch McConnell
is telling the moderates they're lying
to all of you so even the main thrust of
the bill which was to cut Medicaid
expansion it's not even cutting Medicaid
it's cutting Medicaid expansion in the
future even the main thrust of it
McConnell saying is never going to go
into place which means that you're
basically keeping Obamacare in place the
other major provision that changes is
Ted Cruz and Michael Lee had proposed an
amendment the amendment would have said
that if you are in an Obamacare state
and has an Obamacare exchange you are
still subject to Obamacare regulations
on pre-existing conditions and and
essential benefits services and all the
like but if you offer one of those plans
in the health care exchange then you can
offer other plans outside the health
care exchange so the reason that matters
is because if it's inside the health
care exchange it still has to provide
certain benefits it has to be subsidized
by the government
you're grouped together with other
people in terms of Community Rating so
the way that go cruising lis we're
thinking about it was okay here's what
we should do we'll still have the
Obamacare pool though those will be
basically high-risk pools and we'll
subsidize them and we'll toss money into
it and then all the healthy people they
can opt out and buy cheaper insurance so
everyone will get insurance the people
who are unhealthy will get subsidized by
the government to be in the Obamacare
exchange the people who are healthy will
go back to having a free-market system
where they don't have to buy insurance
then want to buy Meccano comes back with
a version of this but the version of it
that he proposes doesn't make any sense
instead of separating out these other
plans these low-cost plans it throws
them into the obamacare exchange as well
which means they're still subject to the
Obamacare regulations and it means that
the rates on those low cost plans are
actually can go up because
they're all in the pool together that
means they're going to have to pay for
the unhealthy people so you end up back
with Obamacare so basically it's back to
Obamacare again Rand Paul rightly so is
excoriating the bill even yesterday he
was as a piece over at Breitbart where
he says I missed the old days when
Republicans stood for repealing
Obamacare so now too many Republicans
are falling all over themselves to stuff
hundreds of billions of taxpayer dollars
into a bill that doesn't repeal
Obamacare and feeds big insurance a huge
bailout right this is all the subsidies
for these high-risk pools because
Obamacare regulations still here taxes
many still in place totaling hundreds of
billions of dollars insurance company
bailouts those to remember when
Republicans complain about Obama cares
risk corridors remember when we called
corridors nothing more than insurance
company bailouts
I remember when one prominent GOP
candidate during the presidential debate
explicitly called out Obamacare risk
corridors as a bailout to insurance
companies does anyone else now the GOP
plan being put out forward is full of
chalk is chock full of insurance bailout
money to the tune of nearly 200 billion
dollars Republicans present company
excluded now support the idea of
lowering your insurance premium by
giving a subsidy to the insurance
company if the GOP now supports an
insurance Stabilization Fund to lower
insurance prices maybe they should
support a new car Stabilization Fund to
lower the price of cars or maybe the GOP
would support an i-phone Stabilization
Fund to lower the price of phones the
possibilities are limitless Rand Paul is
right here listen this was always a
foregone conclusion as soon as they said
repeal and replace and as soon as it was
clear that Donald Trump was never going
to stand for a straight repeal it was
pretty obvious that this was moving in
the wrong direction it's not a it is
just not a it's still not a useful bill
it's so many useful bill they're going
to do their best to try and pass off
this craft and which is something good
as an advance but as we say even the
parts that advance even the parts that I
supported of this bill like the Medicaid
the Medicaid cutbacks
even those restructuring even those are
now being cut according to McConnell
it's all just in name only to get
something through so well done
Republicans once again you have somehow
you know somehow achieved failure out of
what could have been victory what is it
a curry is on the hill President Obama
President Obama president thank God not
president Trump has an FBI director
nominee named Christopher ray
Christopher ray was questioned on the
hill yesterday and he was basically
asked by Congress are you going to be
independent
the President of the United States you
can be a lackey and here's what he had
to say about being like Oh Megan coming
do you see the press conference they
gave about the Hillary Clinton
investigation in July of last year I not
live but yes would you have done that
well senator there is an inspector
general investigation in a director come
on I'm talking about the investigation
I'm asking about you would you have done
that I can tell you that in my
experience as a prosecutor and as head
of the Criminal Division I understand
their did would be department policies
that govern public comments charged
individuals I think those policies are
there for reasons I thought left for
them and I would follow those policy
okay he talked about somebody that was
never charged in this bearing fashion do
you agree with that that's the way I
understood he also agreed that he took
over the prosecutors job by saying
there's no case here
well senator again there's an inspector
general investigation in Connor would
you you would not have done either one
of those is what you're telling this
committee at least I hope that's what
you're telling us kidding I can't
imagine a situation where an FBI
director I would be giving a press
conference on an uncharged individual
much less talk Thank You Hale about it
okay so you know this is of course the
correct answer that he's not gonna be
like James Comey and then he was also
asked about Bob Muller because President
Trump had suggested that the special
prosecutor special counsel that he's on
a witch-hunt against the Trump family
and here was a raise response you say
that Muller is a good guy
all right that's been my experience yes
and you will do anything necessary to
protect him from being interfered with
when it comes to doing his job
absolutely I think he's would you
believe that in light of the Don jr.
email and other allegations that this
whole thing about Trump campaign and
rushes of witch-hunt is that a fair
description of what we're all dealing
with in America well senator I can't
speak to the basis for those comments I
can tell you that my experience with
direct I'm asking you as the future FBI
director you consider this endeavor a
witch hunt I did not consider director
Muller to be on a witch hunt okay so
that is the correct answer rate will be
confirmed you should be
from a bunch of Democrats trying to hold
them up just because they're angry at
Trump and they want to talk about Russia
a lot but Rey will be confirmed he is a
good pick by President Trump the
question is will Trump allow him to do
his job or will Trump interfere and get
angry at him the way he has if Bob
Muller or Reince Priebus or Steve Bannon
or Jared Kushner or every single other
person he's ever appointed to his in the
description so we'll find out but
Christopher Rae will be a fine pick for
FBI he did a good job in his hearings
yesterday okay so I want to get some
things I like things I hate in Big Idea
before I do that I want to say thank you
to our new sponsor dollarshaveclub.com
so as an Orthodox Jew I am NOT somebody
who uses a straightedge above my jawline
I'm asked to make this clear by all be
fellow Orthodox use to listen to the
program and watch the program but I do
shave below my jawline as per Maimonides
with a straightedge razor okay it is
very difficult to get a good sharp
straightedge razor this is of course is
the most difficult part to shave period
I mean Malthus you shave with a straight
edge correct and the hardest part to
shave I would assume is below the
jawline it's not too terrible right and
that's why you need a really great razor
that's why Dollar Shave Club is the
smarter choice they get a great shave at
a great price conveniently delivered
right to your door you no longer have to
head out to the grocery store and spend
1 million dollars on a pack of blades
instead it comes right to your door you
buy one of these razors and they just
work fantastic they have something
called dr. Carver's shave which is a
shave butter it is transparent for more
precise shade so you're not trying to
figure out exactly where the hair is you
know you put on the the foamy white
stuff and then it's like you shave off
all the white stuff and you've still got
the hair underneath right if it's
transparent then you can actually see
where exactly you are shaving you can
make the smarter choice by joining the
Dollar Shave Club for a limited time new
members get their first month of the
executive razor which is this really
nice razor with a tube of their doctrine
convert shave butter for just five
dollars five bucks with Free Shipping
after that razors are just a few bucks a
month which is great because you forget
to replace your razor and then it gets
all rusty and it gets all blunt and then
next thing you know you're you're
basically committing suicide by razor
this is why it is important to have a
regular shipment of razors to your home
and that's what happens with Dollar
Shave Club it's a 15 dollar value for
just five bucks in the first box you get
an awesome way T handle focus out of
four cartridges a tube of their shaved
butter and after that they should
automatically at the
price no hidden fees no commitments
cancel anytime you like
join the club today at
dollarshaveclub.com slash fun that is
dollarshaveclub.com slash pen make sure
you use the splash pen so you get that
discount remember your first month you
get everything for five bucks you get
that fifteen dollar value for five bucks
the executive razor the dr. Carter's
shave butter a coverage shea butter for
five bucks a month plus free shipping
and use that Dollar Shave Club / pen so
they know that we sent you and continue
to advertise with the program okay time
for some things that I like and some
things that I hate so things that I like
we've been doing movies about sons who
have disappointed their fathers this
week we've been doing all sorts of
material on that weighted East of Eden
we've done a bunch of a bunch of
different that we did Arrested
Development we did Pete Rose today it's
in the name of the Father so one of the
great tragedies of this year that has
yet to be remark upon is Nancy Lewis
says that he's retiring from acting
which is just horrifying he hath I mean
Malthus says that he is lying we can
only hope that Malthus is correct
because Daniel day-lewis is the greatest
living actor he is just phenomenal in
every part that he has ever played his
versatility is ridiculous
the only other person I think was even
in his league at this point might be
Christian Bale but it see but even there
I think that it's it's you know eight
plus versus a daniel day was just
phenomenal and everything one of his
earliest films I think he won an Oscar
for this was in the no did he wouldn't
Oscar for this he wanted from my left
foot I'm not sure if he won from the
name of the father but the movie in the
name of the father is a is a really good
film great acting it's about the
Guildford four this is a group of people
who are convicted of terrorism they
apparently confessed under duress they
were convicted of terrorism in an IRA
bombing in the 1970s and and Daniel
day-lewis plays one of the Guildford
four and his father is arrested
basically because he just gets dragged
into this because his son is an arrow do
well and the entire movie is about him
trying to live up to his father's
memories his father dies in prison
great movie is it possible way to place
his death I'm trying to remember who
plays his father but great performance
is all around here's a little bit of a
preview
it was a time of innocence no poverty no
law just love what's recall you coming
welcome one of the partners and Gretel
friends above the jam here any prayer
in the wake of the open pub bombing debt
the government has responded with
emergency legislation and increase
police powers of search and arrest makes
on you are in trouble calling each other
even the murders of five people fill
your mind so we have like the bonus
Jimmy Doohan disperses mirth their
arrest was only the beginning
my name is Giuseppe corner eminence and
answers result
a remarkable journey all of the
defendants fled but they were subjected
to physical and mental abuse while under
police custody
we're never harmed in this entire film
is basically about his relationship with
his father because his father gets
dragged into this and his father's an
honorable man and he really isn't at the
beginning of the film is about how he
learns to live up to his father's
standards in the name of the Father is
the name of the film very very good
movie okay other things that I like so
Bernie Sanders says he wants to run
again which is great I could not be more
excited about this he's asked about will
he run again in 2020 at the age of 1293
and they're already apparently raising
money for pudding cups so here is Bernie
Sanders talking about it
are you leaving 2020 on the table are
you taking it off the table no I'm not
taking it off the table I just have not
made any decision so I think it's watch
too early that means that he's going to
run I mean that he's going to run right
it means whenever someone says I'm not
taking it off the table that means that
he's going to run or in Bernie Sanders
case hobble so that'll be that'll be
great I'm mostly excited about it so
that I can continue to do my Bernie
Sanders impression forever
for years and years and I hope that long
after he passes when he is 120 years old
when he passes that they will his corpse
around and he continues to run so I can
continue to talk about vacation homes
and pudding cups as he so richly
deserves as a crazy socialist who has
two vacation homes and a Towson pudding
cups so that's exciting okay time for
some things that I hate okay so I was I
saw this video on Twitter this morning I
couldn't really believe that it was real
there's some group out there that is
making the case that women should be
paid more than men why because it costs
more to be a woman than it costs to be a
man because you have things like shoes
you have to buy this is perhaps the
worst commercial for closing the pay gap
in the history of humanity and it's a
pretty long list here here is this
commercial and basically it says that
women should break things and and stomp
their feet and whine and cry until they
get what they want that's basically this
commercial is so well done feminists
listen up they're still not equal pay
for equal work in rain world and it
seems most women are not even angry
about it but we should be so let's set a
new goal from now on equal pay is no
longer enough because women this woman
who is kicking a ball ahead has ever
brought their pain our underwear is
ridiculous in more senses it could be
much justice to be a woman since women
should receive it we get paid less than
someone who tries body lotion to escape
she doesn't need a new outfit for any
occasion he doesn't even know that the
shoes make the outfit or to join of
choosing the right shoes with Israel
guys it's not a parody is expressing
yourself and what every stylish woman is
expressing is that equal pain is not
enough quickl pain is not enough again a
woman throws her high-heeled shoe at a
window and shatters the window and the
woman jumped on the hood of the car and
ruins the hood of the car and a woman
takes the mug into her boss's face and a
break mostly the weakest mug of all time
by the way and then she just screaming
at her boss and then it shows a
high-heeled shoe and it says hashtags
women need more bianco I don't know if
Bianco is but that is legitimately the
worst ad for female empowerment I have
ever seen in my entire life because if
the case is that you're going to whine
about the cost of your underwear so I
should pay you more and then you're
going to break my crap because of it you
are fired okay you do not going to raise
you get fired
assault hitting people with bugs bad
things folks you don't get to do this
women should be paid more because their
underwear cost more then what the hell
should I be paid more because my Jewish
rituals cost more they do ok Passover
super expensive should I get paid more
because I'm a Jew would it absolute
utter a Horus nonsense ok other things
that I hate Linda Sarsour has now said
that she is taking names gang she's
taking it she says I just know that I'm
taking
those who have lied about me to defame
my character I may be quiet now but not
for long I am working
be scared of Linda Sarsour okay I'm
honestly more scared of Linda Sarsour as
friends like you know razz me Oda like
actual terrorists then I'm scared of
Linda Sarsour I understand that the West
likes to use law fair I've been the
victim of this that was what happened
with Kwok boy but the anti Islamophobia
scam brigade is up and our lieutenant
was very angry because people are
pointing out things that she said and
she doesn't like it when people point
out things that she said so pretty
pretty amazing so Linda Sarsour yeah
okay fine she's like evil Santa Claus
checking from making a list and checking
it twice
okay other things that I hate Riley
Dennis is a prominent transgender person
on Twitter and Riley Dennis is a he
because he is a man is he is saying that
his argument is a direct well quote my
argument may be your preference for
women with vaginas over women with
penises is to some degree influenced by
our sis sexist society as a Riley Dennis
who is a man with a penis I believe I
don't know about the surgical status
Reilly Dennis I'm fairly certain on this
and believes he is a woman he says that
your desire not to have sex with a man
because he's a man is because you are
cisgender not because of things like
science right he says it's because the
reason the reason that you as a straight
man only one have sex with women you
know like actual women with vaginas and
chromosomes and such the only reason
you'd want to do that is because of
sexism in society there's another reason
it is called evolution okay it's called
procreation
like God made things this way nature for
you don't have to be a theist to believe
this
nature may think that men who on aspects
of women won't have sex with women who
actually have the body parts that
produce children because that is what
nature desires pull insanity okay final
thing so usually we do big ideas on
Thursday I can do this in about a minute
30 so we'll do big ideas on we'll do big
ideas here on ben shapiro show this is
where i think an idea that I think has
been under discussed and we talked about
it so that you know more about it so due
process of law so there's been a lot of
talk about whether
from jr. broke the law this week as
though Donald Trump jr. a collusion is a
crime and I keep saying no collusion is
not a crime you actually have to cite me
the statute and people I'm not going
that's a crime it's bad bad means it's a
crime no bad does not mean it's a crime
due process of law means there must be a
law on the books that you have violated
and now we take you to trial and then
you get a lawyer and then we decide
whether you are guilty or innocent
that's what due process of law means
it's under the Fifth Amendment and the
Fourteenth Amendment now the left is so
bizarre that they believe there should
be no due process of law for people like
Donald from jr. but they also believe in
this concept this idiotic concepts
called substantive due process
substantive due process is a Supreme
Court term that is self-contradictory
process and substance are opposites okay
it's like saying it's like saying red
sky blue okay that's not how it works
substantive due process doesn't make any
sense but the concept is that if you
pass a law I don't like you have
violated my due process right that's not
what you process means due process means
that once the laws in place I now get a
due process of law before it is enforced
upon me but the West has been using
substantive due process to cram down
abortion and the so-called rights of
privacy and same-sex marriage they say
that any law against these things
violates your due process rights no it
does not violate your due process rights
in fact the concept of substantive due
process was actually coined by Justice
xx in the infamous and horrific Dred
Scott decision in which he actually said
that an act of Congress which deprives a
citizen of the United States of his
liberty or property merely because he
came himself or brought his property
into a particular territory of the
United States and who had committed no
offense against the laws could hardly be
dignified with the name of due process
of laws what he said is that if you're
say your slave escapes into the north
and you go there and then you want to
bring your slave back you should be
allowed to bring your slave back because
otherwise you are being deprived of your
property without due process of law
except for the fact that has nothing to
do with anything okay that's not due
process of law due process of law would
mean there would have to be a trial to
determine whether you get your slave
back or not in this context but it
doesn't mean that you get to
automatically overthrow the law because
your due process has been denied due
process of law is very important
substantive due process by contrast is a
supreme court adjudicated evil that
allows them to do whatever they want so
I thought that it was worthwhile
elucidating that concept
okay we will be back here tomorrow it's
a Thursday today correct so tomorrow is
the long waited mailbag we're going to
do the interview with Mark Levin today
we'll be doing that tomorrow as well on
the show so the great one will be
joining us tomorrow to talk about his
brand-new new number one New York Times
best selling book and that will be
awesome so be there or be square I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]